around the world people are beginning to
contemplate a life after lockdown china
appeared to have passed the work of
spain is returning to work germany is
due to end social distancing measures in
a week's time and governments are
grappling with what to do next with no
way to eradicate covert 19 and the
ever-present risk of a resurgence what's
the right way to leave lock down placing
more than a third of the world's
population into lockdown has done much
to slow the spread of the new
coronavirus but there's a big price to
pay the problem is that it's incredibly
damaging to the economy and that has
real consequences for people's lives the
lockdown is really just a very intense
form of social distancing and you want
to relax that as much as possible so you
want to work out which elements of the
social distancing have most effect on
the disease but the least effect on the
way people leave their lives the trouble
is no one is certain what the right
formula is so governments will need to
strike a delicate balance and take a
very cautious approach to which measures
they loosen how and when take for
example the tricky question of getting
children back to school countries like
Denmark and Germany have looked at the
European schools although under very
strict conditions which means you have a
sort of social distancing within the
classroom good luck with that
as with other social distancing measures
making the wrong call on this could lead
to a resurgence of the disease but given
the broad impact of school closures on
children and their parents and that
young children in particular may not be
as vulnerable to the effects of covert
19 there is a case for trying to reopen
schools sooner rather than later
China has already pioneered the use of
social distancing measures within
schools to enable them to reopen so far
the country has avoided a second wave of
infection which is why there may be
other lessons to learn from China's
staggered return to daily life from
capping the number of people allowed in
restaurants and public places to
severely limiting the number of workers
that firms can have on site each day
social distancing isn't a binary
phenomenon the way to think of it as a
series of measures each of which does a
little bit to reduce the spread of the
disease at a particular inconvenience or
cost of society an element of trial and
error is inevitable which means
governments will need to be prepared to
tighten the rules again if new
infections start to mount a second
element which helps you with all of that
is testing and contact tracing to detect
people who have a disease identify all
the people they have been in touch with
contact then test them put them in
isolation if any of them are infectious
then you contact the people that they
are in touch with tracking the virus in
this way is an essential strategy if
countries are to become less dependent
on social distancing you can concentrate
all I have had on the people who are
most likely to have the disease a
corollary of that is the people who you
don't have to contact are freer to move
around and they otherwise would be it's
a huge task but technology may be able
to offer a shortcut Apple Google are
teaming up to work on technology to help
reduce the spread of corona virus to
help deliver contact tracing to
Americans and people around the world
the idea is that when Apple and Android
phones can work together and be in touch
with each other leave if someone's
infected you can go back over the log
that shows you all the people they've
been in touch with and identify very
very rapidly you know who the contacts
have been and then direct your testing
to them
Germany Ireland and America are among
the countries now building infection
tracking apps that could run on Apple
and Google's new protocol governments
could use these apps to create a form of
covert 19 passport classifying
individuals by whether they tested
positive or not that's a system that
you've had used pretty thoroughly in
China such that people have to show
their phone and show they've got a green
status which means they can travel
around but to feel the benefits of this
innovative approach governments are
going to have to really invest it
doesn't work unless you also have an
army of testers to go around and follow
up these leads test all the people
ensure that they're keeping their
quarantine research suggests that
America alone would need to employ
another 100,000 contact tracers at a
cost of around 3.6 billion dollars the
other thing is you need the physical
tests you need the reagents you need all
the materials and you need them
manufactured on an immense scale without
this further lockdowns could become
inevitable the less good your testing
and the less good your contact tracing
the more general and harmful actually
the lockdown has to be in order to
create the same effect you have a big
broad net to catch the same number of
infectious people a third element is to
make your health system more robust
when health systems get swamped then the
number of deaths really goes up fast so
you can invest now in equipping medics
with all the protection they need having
enough ventilators having enough ICU
beds which means that if the disease
does start to pick up the consequences
are less bad of course there's the
ultimate way to return to daily life
scientists in Oxford are hoping to have
a million doses of a corona virus
vaccine by September 3 vaccines are
already in clinical trials - in the
United States one in China there are
many vaccine candidates in development
in the year or more it may take to
deliver an effective vaccine government
should be preparing for the next
challenge producing it finding the
vaccine is one thing but then you have
to manufacture it at scale and that
would be really quite hard part of the
answer is to start building
manufacturing plants now at a cost of
billions of dollars before an effective
vaccine has been found without this
investment there will be a shortage of
manufacturing capacity and as long as
there's a shortage some countries are
likely to push to the front of the queue
there's a danger that different
countries try and corner the market for
their own citizens which is
understandable but not very good for the
world because it means that vulnerable
populations and really key workers like
health care workers who need protection
or to care for everybody else they will
go short locating manufacturing plants
across the world could help counter this
vaccine nationalism and ensure the
vaccine reaches those most in need
long before there's any vaccine to be
distributed governments have more
pressing calls to make on the right way
to leave lockdown with few certainties
to guide them they'll need to be nimble
versatile and have vast reserves of
patience for a return to everyday life
there will be anything but business as
usual
hi I'm a trick car The Economist deputy
editor it's amazing in just how a few
short months the coronavirus story has
come to dominate everything we do so
we'd like to see more of our coverage
please click on the link opposite thank
you for watching
[Music]